the first question is what does Europe
do I think the United States has been
very clear in both its criticism of
Russia and Putin its support for
poroshenko in the new Ukrainian
government and there has just been a new
round of sanctions that President Obama
himself has announced as you know the
Europeans have tried to figure out the
best way forward
I was recently in Europe a lot of
questions about whether or not Russia
was really the aggressor whether or not
Putin was really dangerous how could
that be evaluated from my perspective
and I have the benefit of not being in
the government if there is evidence
linking Russia to this that should
inspire the Europeans to do much more on
three counts one toughen their own
sanctions make it very clear there has
to be a price to pay
number two immediately accelerate
efforts and announce they are doing so
to find alternatives to gas prom you
know Russia has not diversified its
economy it is still largely dependent
upon natural resources principally gas
and oil and thirdly do more in concert
with us
to support the Ukrainians there has to
be more help on their borders in order
to prevent this porous border allowing
Russians to go back and forth insurgents
to do the same do more to help their
military obtain better equipment better
training the Ukrainian military under
poroshenko has been much more focused
and more successful but nobody kids
themselves if Russia really keeps
weighing in on behalf of the insurgents
there's a lot more that needs to be done
and to put Putin on notice that he has
gone too far and we are not going to
stand idly by
so Europeans have to be the ones to take
the lead on this it was a flight from
amsterdam to kuala lumpur over european
territory there should be outrage in
european capitals